who loves fans of TV so they found out
and breathed
[Music]
with their friends they talk
TV so you know what to stream
[Music]
Our Guest today is the hilarious Sherry
Cola thank you so much for being hello
thank you for having me I didn't bring a
bottle of wine but I did bring this
personality okay that's always just as
good win-win so we're talking about some
of our favorite comfort TV shows today
we thought we'd kick it off with one of
our favorite topics delicious dramas
Double Double D's but you just want to
sink your teeth into you know it's like
the holidays are going on you just want
to relax and turn on something you can
just veg out on that's the bingeability
of itability I love that one new word TM
absolutely I mean y'all are pretty much
describing good trouble which is the
show I'm on I have to talk about it
I love it you're so funny by the way
stop yes no you keep going okay you're
super funny adjectives you're really
blushing wait no I'm intrigued I don't
know what it is
so in the world of people in their 20s
messy flawed downtown L.A yeah fighting
for something in their own way everyone
has a an arc and love triangles love
trapezoids oh love octagons good wow
that's a lot of shapes colors diversity
inclusion Equity La I mean really the
title is you know named after the late
great John Lewis's beautiful words you
know so I think it's a show for everyone
I do love though because the first
episode you have two sisters who like
just graduated from college seeing them
deal with you know just what a young
woman going into the corporate world
would deal with you know and it's not
it's not even necessarily over the top
cliche of like you've got to fight your
way to the top like they have people on
their side and then they have people not
on their side so it's it's refreshing to
see that tape you know exactly yeah very
well said people know that you say that
like young woman like getting out of
college going into the workforce I
watched younger who is about a woman in
her 40s pretending to be 26 to get into
the workforce younger well first of all
Hilary Duff I will die for I will watch
her in absolutely anything even that
added layer of her like lying to be
younger like yeah and then like lying to
absolutely everyone having a daughter
who's like studying abroad yeah who
wants to come back like okay you guys
are selling this for me I haven't
watched that one yet well you guys are
making me want to watch no there's
nothing more Universal than lying yeah
you know and that's what I want to see
the lead character do and it's actually
a really interesting twist that they
started with that yeah you know I mean
that's not a spoiler because it's
literally in the first episode right off
the bat she has like such good like
reasons for it like she's gonna have to
she wants her second ass she just you
know that and she wants like to keep her
home right against stability yeah
Logistics I feel like also the drama
like is that you know there's like a
drama Cry Sometimes a trauma no
I don't hate it quit
no what about reality shows you guys
into any reality shows lately I think
for me what I find most comforting about
reality TV is just like it's like a just
a companion that's there with me while
I'm free to kind of do what I need to
get done like I could be on my phone
right if something gets really good I
can stop and watch I just like watching
other people's drama for a change you
know I love claim to fame what is that
one tell me basically there's a house of
strangers to each other but everyone is
related to an individual celebrity so
every person has a famous relative then
you have to guess uh who everyone is
related to I was just like all that
stuff there's like a game show element
yeah you know what I love about
competition series is that even though
there can only be one winner they kind
of bond you know and they kind of form
alliances to the point where well you
care about this person you don't want to
throw them under the bus but you also
want 10 million thousand dollars for the
kids to go to college I just started
this new show called Joe Millionaire
have you guys heard of it that like came
back right yes so it's these two guys
one guy is worth 10 million dollars one
guy is not they get a bunch of girls in
the house and they all are going to be
dating the guys but the girls don't know
which one is Rich and which one isn't
so but I think it's interesting because
the guy who's really wealthy you know
he's like oh I just want to meet someone
who loves me for me and I'm like but the
girls know that one of you is Rich so
I'm just I that's so interesting to me I
wonder how that like would you really be
able to trust them like it's 50 50. so
all the women are gambling addicts yes
essentially the thing is I don't think
the other guys like dirt poor it's not
like he's never seen the inside of a
salon before but like just one guy's
worth 10 million dollars and one guy
isn't that's exactly what the host
that's exams oh and it's it's this
Butler that's what I was gonna uh right
this way does anyone go home with the
butler
um we'll see if I you know if I was one
of the girls yeah oh we'll find out I
don't know I'll let you know I'll get to
the finale I'll watch as well yeah and
text personally I love comedies I think
the most universal love language is
comedy and there's so many good shows
out there right now I feel like cozy
really is the word because it's so
familiar and so different from a drama
because the drama you're on the edge of
your seat you're anxious you know what I
mean you're sweating you want answers
yeah but with these sitcoms they exist
just by episode you can put on you know
season three episode seven and you're
you're good you're not so true they
really are like Jump Right In one of my
top ten easily of all time comedies
Bob's Burgers I every I don't know what
it is but every time the theme song
starts and they're all standing out in
front of the rush I actually get
emotional I'm like I'm laughing I'm
crying I'm sweating I'm peeing I'm
lactating
also the fact that the kids never get
older right I don't know if that's
weirdly comfortable because it's the
same thing in The Simpsons and Family
Guy like in all of those like true
Staples of like animated shows like
nobody grows up interesting I know I can
always go back to them right you know
like they're not gonna change and
there's and the stories never get boring
yeah it's every season it gets better
and better and better yeah but they're
the constant well that's too deep no not
too deep because I want to go deeper
cartoons are Timeless in that way right
because sometimes the real life human
kids grow too fast
foreign
[Music]